welcome to the special report homepage  I'm Bret Baier we had a good discussion  on the panel tonight about tonight's  scheduled dinner between Secretary of  State Pompeo and a top North Korean  official as part of ongoing talks to  resurrect a summit you can see the  segment right here on the website along  with the report by John Roberts also in  the home page Howard Kurtz with the  latest on the Rosanne cancellation and  what she's blaming for that infamous  tweet Thursday Iran's leaders threatened  to crack down on growing public unrest  in the Islamic Republic we'll give you  the latest 6:00 p.m. Eastern on Fox News  Channel 4 special report